[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i'm going to
explain the action horror film called it
came from the desert spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
the movie begins with what seems like a
ball of fire falling from the sky and
crashing into the desert in new mexico
leaving behind a humongous hole in the
ground the movie then fast forwards to
67 years later alarms are going off
inside a hidden facility in the same
desert armed men are running in fear
looking for a safe exit while battling
what seems like huge ants bigger in size
than all humans unfortunately one by one
all of the men fall and none of them
make it out alive the movie then cuts to
two cowboys jorge and his pal driving in
their nissan truck in the desert they
stop at the edge of a chasm and notice a
tunnel at the bottom they bring out
their concrete trolley and venture into
the tunnel to fetch any scrap copper
they can find the tunnel leads to a
desolate facility called the chicane
industries as jorge inspects the ground
for metal he is suddenly attacked by
giant ants sending his partner running
back to the truck in fear however before
he could reach the vehicle the ants get
to him the movie then cuts to a guy
named brian watching a movie called the
eradicator on his tv in his garage in
the tv film a blonde girl is being
attacked by a hideous monster and calls
out for john eradicator cage the male
protagonist for help the eradicator then
shows up in a fancy sports bike he
sprays the green monster with bullets
and rescues the girl like in any cheesy
hollywood movie the two make out as
brian vicariously lives through the
movie imagining himself as the
eradicator brian is a nerdy university
student who works part-time as a
mechanic and repairs racing bikes
brian's cool racer best friend lucas
then shows up and asks him to hurry up
for a party brian and lucas are excited
for the party as the eradicator himself
is gracing the event and awarding lucas
his medal for winning his university's
extreme sports bike race as they load
lucas's sports bike on their pickup
truck a missing person's poster is seen
on a nearby tree put up by the shekane
industries instead of driving to the
desert party lucas drives in the
opposite direction which leads to
brian's major crush lisa's home lucas
reveals that he has invited her to the
party without telling brian brian freaks
out and tells him to stop but lucas
tells him that one day or another he
will have to man up and express his
feelings for her lisa goes to the same
university as brian and lucas she is not
only beautiful and cool she is smart
like brian after picking up lisa they
head to the party geeking out over the
eradicator franchise halfway to the
party the guarisco brothers show up on
their bikes they flaunt their bike
stunts forcing lucas to prove that he is
no less lucas asks brian to take over
the steering wheel and jumps from the
truck with his bike to show tim and
craig guarisco who the real boss is the
two brothers don't see eye to eye with
lucas and have a war of words with each
other after reaching the party brian
defuses the situation and asks everyone
to just enjoy the party at the party
lucas again encourages brian to talk to
lisa but brian feels he doesn't have a
cool personality and can't do daredevil
stunts like lucas lucas asks him to stop
his pity party and suggests that he
confidently ask her out because that's
what girls like however before brian
could even approach her craig and tim
start hitting on her and brian again
loses hope as lucas gets busy on stage
thanking everyone for coming to his
party brian wanders into the desert
while acknowledging brian's major
contribution in his victory lucas
notices that brian is missing from the
crowd and goes looking for him he finds
him on the edge of the chasm they both
notice jorge's abandoned truck on the
other side of the chasm and the tunnel
down below lucas forces brian to come
along with him to check out the tunnel
they come across the chicane industries
facility which brian says is one of the
biggest military contractors in the u.s
afraid of getting shot brian advises
against entering the private property
but lucas doesn't heed his advice as
they inspect the elaborate military
facility lisa comes looking for them by
the chasm inside the desolate facility
brian and lucas come across a mess hall
and kitchen with a refrigerator that is
still cold and operating they decide to
go further into the facility and find a
room labeled batch nine inside they find
gooey liquids and webs they suddenly
hear strange sounds coming from outside
frightened lucas finally decides to get
the hell out of the facility however as
they head for the exit they come across
a giant ant in the mess hall and quickly
hide in the kitchen lucas gets a call
from lisa and he tells her that they are
stuck in the facility with a giant ant
he manages to ask her to come down to
the tunnel and help them before his
phone dies with no choice other than to
fight they arm themselves with wait for
it a takoyaki pan and grill spatula
they're going to stir-fry that bastard
the ant eventually finds them in the
kitchen and their weapons prove to be
useless
the two buddies run to the mess but the
ant jumps over them and blocks their
exit it corners lucas but brian bravely
saves his friend by luring the ant
towards himself he then slides towards
the exit but the ant again jumps over
him and blocks him from running away
brian hits the button next to the exit
and the gate begins to close however the
ant grabs him and tries to pull him
towards itself
lucas rushes towards his friend and
tries to pull him out but the ant starts
pulling both of them towards itself the
two guys almost resign but suddenly lisa
appears on the other side and starts
hammering the ant eventually killing the
monster lucas celebrates the victory
while lisa speculates that more such
ants could attack them as wounded ants
emit alarm pheromones that send nearby
ants into an attack frenzy and attract
more ants from farther away i wonder if
lisa had an explanation for the ant
jumping lisa's prophecy quickly comes
true and more ants arrive from outside
forcing them to go deeper into the
facility and hide they realize that they
are in some sort of control room
suddenly a video starts to play on one
of the computers and a man named dr john
renard head of the u.s military project
them speaks he reveals that in 1951 a
meteor brought alien creatures to earth
the u.s contained the creatures and kept
them for testing and experimentation
using a piece of the original alien dna
scientists spliced their dna from fire
ants and spiders to create the giant
creatures for military research purposes
but one day due to a security breach the
batch nine broke free and killed all
private security forces moreover one
dozen scientists have gone missing and
are presumed dead dr renard speculates
that after feeding the batch nine will
attempt to make a colony somewhere dark
and cool where the queen ant can lay
eggs he also reveals that the ants
require ethanol to fertilize the eggs
lisa suddenly realizes that their desert
party has an endless supply of ethanol
aka alcohol and the trio quickly head to
the party to warn the others
however the army of ants reaches the
party before them and launches an attack
sending everyone into a frenzy tim and
craig quickly hop on their bikes and
proceed to flee while others become
victims of the ants one by one a small
group of ants follows the guaresco
brothers and manages to trip craig and
capture him while tim helplessly drives
away brian and his friends finally
arrive and learn that the ants have
already wreaked havoc at the party they
decide to head to the town but as soon
as they get on their trucks they come
under attack by an ant they freak out
and get on two bikes and drive away they
split up to trick the ants and brian
heads towards the chasm with lisa
planning to jump over the fissure this
might be the wrong time for brian to try
a stunt however lisa tells him that he
can't make it to the other side and
trips the bike over to stop him brian
gets upset that she feels he can't jump
over the chasm because she probably
thinks that lucas can lisa corrects him
and tells him that lucas can't make it
to the other side either brian tells her
that lucas would at least try lisa
agrees but tells him that's why she
thinks lucas is an idiot she reminds
brian that just because they are in a
dire situation doesn't mean he has to do
anything reckless i guess lisa doesn't
know that she's in an action movie she
tells him that he is smarter than that
and that's why she likes him brian is
taken aback by the confession and gets
lost in his thoughts meanwhile an ant
quietly takes elisa away brian snaps out
of his dreams and lucas arrives the two
follow the ant to the star caves deep
inside the caves they come across giant
glowing ant eggs they also find lisa and
their friends from the party wrapped
alive inside silk cocoons suddenly an
ant shows up but dr renard appears from
behind and kills it the scientist tells
them that they must leave immediately
before the other ants return brian
refuses to leave without lisa but dr
renard tells him that they can't open
the cocoon without special tools lucas
tells his friend that if they all die no
one will be able to save lisa and brian
finally agrees to leave but not before
promising lisa that he will return to
get her as they head towards the
facility to fetch tools required to
rescue lisa and the others on foot dr
renard warns them that automated sentry
guns protecting the facility must have
been activated after the release of his
sos video he also shows them a map
containing the locations of the sentry
guns around the facility he further
reveals that the ants will start looking
for other sources of prey i.e the
nearest town which leaves the trio with
30 minutes to act halfway to the
facility an ant appears from behind and
impales the scientist horrified brian
and lucas run away and enter the
facility from the back to avoid getting
shelled by machine guns passing through
the hallway they come across a giant
gate inside the chamber but fail to open
it dejected they proceeded to return
only to find an ant feeding on a corpse
in the hallway forcing them back into
the chamber lucas suggests calling the
authorities but brian fears that the
government could nuke the town to stop
the scourge with no other choice left
they decide to take on the ant lucas
first decides to drink a beer in case he
dies and grabs a beer can from the
refrigerator in the adjoining room but
to their astonishment it opens the gate
inside they find a smart rifle plasma
bolt cutter and combat suits fully
equipped they neutralize the ant outside
and head to the star caves in bikes
parked outside brian quietly frees lisa
and then lures the ants outside the cave
to give lucas freedom to free other
people and destroy the ant eggs brian
leads the ants to the facility setting
them up to get shelled by the automatic
machine guns the plan works and they
celebrate but only to realize that the
queen ant is still alive and watching
over them from above
fearing for their lives they drive
towards the chasm followed closely by
the ant brian initially hesitates to
jump over the fissure but lisa gives him
some encouragement and they successfully
make it to the other side the two then
proceed to flee in jorge's abandoned
pickup truck but the queen ant starts
pulling them towards herself with silk
threads lisa opens fire on the ant but
the ant manages to take down their truck
along with itself the two do what
gandalf could not and jump out of the
truck and barely make it out alive
meanwhile after sending everyone to
safety lucas proceeds to set the nest on
fire but an egg hatches and the baby ant
attacks lucas accidentally setting the
nest on fire in the process brian and
lisa arrive outside the cave to learn
that lucas is still inside brian
proceeds to head in but tim stops him
telling him that lucas saved their lives
and he wouldn't want his best friend
endangering his life craig arrives on
his bike and learns that lucas saved
everyone's life but is still stuck
inside craig who knows that he's a
useless character anyway immediately
starts his bike and heads into the cave
as brian and the others nervously wait
the cave eventually explodes and out
comes craig with lucas safe and sound
everyone erupts into cheers and hugs
each other forgetting whatever animosity
they may have had the group returns to
their party and the eradicator finally
arrives brian is excited to see his idol
and offers him his last beer however a
giant ant appears from behind and
snatches the beer scaring the crap out
of the hero however brian lucas and lisa
do not cower down and point guns at the
creature subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thanks for
watching